citizens of the reject Nation Greg and Coy
here today John already left and then Corner
we were we're gonna go work out together and then
suddenly a a Blue Beetle trailer came out and I
was like okay well let's just film this real
quick then before we got our secret Invasion
midnight show tonight koi I'm glad you're here
still uh how are you feeling buddy uh pre-workout
I'm very I I was gonna hike with you and now
we got a Blue Beetle I have uh caffeinated and
I got creatine in my system so I am pumped
for this ladies and gentlemen leave a like
check out the other trailers we already covered
earlier this morning let's see what's going on
I am real quick before we're going to the trailer
uh sdcc uh Comic-Con panel Saturday July 22nd one
o'clock P.M if you guys are going to Comic-Con
please go check out our panel would love to talk
to you afterwards or before who knows we don't
really play by the rules come back be there
[Music]
I want to play
it's dutch angle blue tracksuit
you've got to force it to come out what do you
you're a genius I know like what'd I say laughs
nice nice work suit is gorgeous oh did
you know what was going to happen to my
brother when you stuck him with this world
destroying thing it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate he has to
choose you so how do we get it to unchoose me
who said that systems
oh yeah
overreacting
and drinking post-production
oh God every time it's great eliminated
Deadpool eye vibes the government
is gonna do correct yeah
the world with the power of the Scarab
it belongs to me what is she powering
oh he's pissed let's see it indestructible there
it is [Applause] nice oh that was great I swear
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal anything please
that's more like it
I got chills man
for your family makes makes you weak you're wrong
yes good to generic hero line oh I
forgot how bad it was it's a family
oh
we saw the Aunt May moment
come on come on [Laughter] I advise
Batman is the fastest let's not
forget the line that broke feet
that wasn't in this one they made sure George
Lopez you know what man I oh god with everything
that's been happening with DC lately and you know
I know we're transitioning to the DCU James going
to stated that the Blue Beetle will be the first
character in the DCU the first official movie will
be Superman Legacy I really hope this does well
because the first trailer was good really good I
thought this was a great trailer this was really
really great it gave me chills indestructible man
while like having a little bit of like some
cliches who gives a [__] alright it looks
awesome uh but cholo looks incredible and the cast
looks so fun I'm really really rooting for this
one I I I it's DC such an underdog right now and
I am really rooting for this film dude I actually
if this was a different trailer it might have
been like we should still work out like I came
back like there's something about this movie he's
the underdog and this the studio is the underdog
right now like if it wasn't a Blue Beetle trailer
I might have been like gains though like this is a
movie that I want to do well personally because
I really like sholo it's a studio that I really
believe in it's a property that I care about I
love that it ties into court Industries in a way
that's interesting because it looks like karnax is
going to be our like middle bad with you know uh
the bigger bad behind the scenes Emperor Palpatine
kind of situation right right but I like that he
if they were the same age that'd be like your Iron
Man almost Iron Monger relationship like that that
you know texture of things but since he's more of
a Spider-Man it allows what would have maybe been
like a Green Goblin situation if they knew each
other but I like that it's like a stranger with
similar powers that doesn't identify with like
this moral code like I like when villains and
heroes uh are the antithesis of each other and I
like that he seems like he's just a bad guy but
sometimes that's what I want in a Villain Like
I don't want him to be mustached worldly but I
like that it's just like no money and power yeah
I mean going off where you're standing impression
that I'm getting is that Susan surround his
character uh Victoria cord who I believe is
a sister I think that's what they're going with
and that's the comic I just hope that's what they
stick with because Ted chord's great yeah so uh I
believe that she will be more of the intelligent
ruthless business type of woman villain monologue
kind of lady Exposition and she'll be the one who
to deliver like all the lines and goodies and then
you'll get more of like the silent badass muscle
yeah in car packs right and I love that Susan
Sarandon like she always brings the gravitas
to the roles and that automatically makes the
chords more interesting because Ted cord is the
original Blue Beetle and I'm wondering how much
they're gonna play with the legacy of Blue Beetle
here because the original Blue Beetle is a very
different character the original blue Beatles
like a buddy cop with Booster Gold the original
Beetle has like you know the the billions and
has a lot of those Iron Man things but it looks
like they're doing a mix of like Iron Man meets
the Spider-Man suit with AI meets Deadpool here
this looks like a blend of a lot of that young
hero but also with some of the more classic
well classic now to the MCU character percent
so with Sigourney Weaver playing the sister of
the original Blue Beetle I'm curious about the
Legacy because they also uh I don't know if you
saw the quote this week but Show Low said that
if you're a fan of the DC Universe there will
be other characters you recognize here oh cool
so that to me is like James Gunn has said it's
the first DCU character we get a DCU film with
Superman but if someone gets introduced here it
might not just be Blue Beetle that carries over
that intrigues me that that intrigues us all
koi I appreciate you saying all of that but
yeah man this movie overall it looks like it
actually looks great great action has a great
family Dynamic to it was that the Nana at the end
yeah that was adorable can I say this movie looks
very expensive and I mean not in a good way it
looks expensive with a great family Dynamic to
it and I love that because Jaime is such a young
character and they're leaning into the fact that
he is in a lot of ways the uh a spider-man-esque
Peter Parker s kind of character except he really
does have a much or Spider-Man was a lot more of
a loner he's got a much you know tighter family
bond unit you know and to see that especially with
like a Latino based kind of film yeah uh that's
it's just so smart and the physicality I love the
physicality of it being a practical suit with an
actor that has physicality like he actually does
martial arts he actually moves well so I love that
they put much like Ryan Reynolds who's one of
the best mimes that doesn't get credit for it
he's got this fighting physicality that since the
suit is practical you feel the weight of it and I
feel like that's really important and what I
miss about some of the later era Spider-Man
I think Andrew Garfield Spider-Man got the most
time in the suit that felt like he got the spider
elements this looks like the fighting elements
from you know karate kid from him being a martial
artist really serve the character even if it's
just flying around and you know what I also love
that it feels kind of refreshing about this as so
many movies nowadays I feel like we kind of even
when if it's a new character we're introducing
we kind of skip over the origin aspect of it or
they like they set them up right away and then
we see some of their origin and flashbacks or
something I like that we're just getting an origin
story again you know it's refreshing it's weird
because we don't get those that often anymore
and Superman isn't Gonna Be An Origin movie
because we have seen Superman so many times so
it's also kind of nice that if this does well
see it it will be a thing where we get an origin
movie starts to DCU in a way yeah like having an
origin movie start the DCU then having Superman a
character we all know that's kind of a beautiful
twofer yeah for sure for sure impressed I love
the trailer love this one a lot liked it more
than the last one guys what did you think about
it leave your nitpicks down below is Batman a
fascist uh subscribe check us out at Comic Con
we're gonna have a panel Saturday July 22nd at
1pm and Cory and I we gotta go work out so we'll
see you guys soon thanks for being here guys bye
thank you